les trois courses devait passer ici les
dix les 20 depuis le marathon sur ce
parcours bucolique tous les coureurs de
tous reconnaissent et puis ensuite à
arriver sur la belle vue de tous rangs
magnifique tout était prêt les parcours
étaient calées chaque année le marathon
de tours réuni plusieurs milliers de
coureurs collés les uns aux autres c'est
cette proximité mais aussi le manque de
visibilité qui a conduit l'organisation
annuler l'édition
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de protocole
sanitaire qui existe et même s'il y en
avait sur une course comme la nôtre
années 2000 coureurs on voit pas comment
on va pouvoir mettre en place
vraiment des mesures sanitaires et puis
la troisième chose évidemment c'est
financière avec des investissements
qu'on aurait dû faire à partir du 1er
juillet des lourds investissements plus
de 150000 euros
car en juillet il fallait passer
commande aux différents prestataires
sans aucune certitude sur la faisabilité
réelle de la course il a paru plus
raisonnable de tout arrêter maintenant
même si forcément il y aura des déçus il
en allait de la survie même de cette
épreuve
j'étais vraiment utile et c'était
vraiment pour moi un challenge quoi oui
et donc vous êtes entraîné quand ça
pendant combien de temps ah ben
quasiment tous les jours 5 matin sur 7
c'était un entraînement entraînement oui
vous l'avez déjà couru le 10 ou le vin
le disent ouais ouais les dernières
n'ont pas forcément que on avait envie
de refaire ses déceptions
le comité d'organisation laisse le choix
soit ils remboursent les inscriptions
soient ils proposent un report sur
l'édition 2021 les organisateurs
planchent aussi sur l'idée de laisser
des coureurs faire librement grâce à une
application et une montre connectés
l'une des trois épreuves durant le mois
de septembre
l'objectif est de se faire plaisir sans
prendre le moindre risque